vendredi stéphanie à une fonctionnaire
de police du commissariat de rambouillet
dans les yvelines a été tué à coups de
couteau dans le sas du commissariat
alors qu'elle rentrait de sa pause
déjeuner le choc et l'émotion suscitée
par cette attaque
la victime s'appelait stéphanie égorgé
dans le commissariat de rambouillet
l'auteur des faits un ressortissant
tunisien âgé de 36 ans arrivé en france
en 2009 est régularisée en 2019
inconnu des services de police il sera
battu par un des policiers présents sur
place après avoir crié allah ouakbar
avant de se jeter sur sa collègue se
note rappelle douloureusement d'autres
drames commis dans la région récemment
nous avons tous en mémoire
l'odieux attentat de magnanville un 2016
et plus récemment l'assassinât de samuel
pâti des meurtres qui nous amène tous à
crier plus jamais ça ce soir cyril armé
d'un kg un de ses amis et collègues
vient lui rendre hommage sur notre
plateau
merci cyril d'être avec nous ce soir
vous êtes déjà venu nous voir pour
d'autres choses sur ce plateau il a vous
êtes un collègue de stéphanie et c'est
vrai que on est on a tous été encore
très très touché et tout ce vraiment ça
joue dit ça nous a bouleversés
bouleversé vendredi j'ai vu des photos
de stéphanie jeune encore regardé cet
après midi et c'est vrai que voilà j'ai
été fort été bouleversé par pas par ce
qui s'est passé comme tous les étés
spectateurs comme tous les français qui
nous regarde ce qui s'est passé vendredi
après midi exactement puisque vous êtes
également de rambouillet c'est ça tout à
fait là vous revenez de l'hommage
d'ailleurs un secret à stéphanie qu'est
ce qui s'est passé or vendredi
moi je vais complice et ma journée de
travail
j'étais encore au téléphone avec un
collègue de toulouse syndicaliste aussi
comme moi qui me dit il ya une dépêche
qui vient de sortir il ya eu à première
vue une attaque commissariat de
rambouillet et il y aurait une femme une
administrative de touché donc qu'est ce
que j'ai fait de suite j'ai téléphoné à
l'administratif qui étaient à l'accueil
qui est une très proches amis
ce que j'avais pas que ça soit elle et
elle me dit non mais je comprends pas je
sais pas qui c'est moi je suis chez moi
donc j'ai appelé une autre de mes
collègues au groupe d'appui judiciaire
qui était à mon service est là elle
venait de la pandera l'été étaient
déchirés et elle me dit c'est stéphanie
vous la connaissez bien stéphanie alors
stéphanie je la connaissais bien tout le
commissariat à la connaissait bien en
soi
c'était une agent administratif qui
gérait notamment le courrier sur
rambouillet elle était fidèle à cette
photo c'est à dire toujours souriante
c'est une femme très calme très discrète
mais toujours toujours disponible pour
ses collègues très très ouverte et très
appréciée pour ça et quand j'ai appris
j'ai dit je vais y aller de suite je me
suis déplacé directement sur les lieux
sur les lieux les premières scellés
avaient été posées tous mes collègues
étaient extrêmement choquée mais juste
la question de tourner ce grossir il
sait que comment un individu peut
rentrer dans un commissariat comme ça et
commettre un tel acte
c'est un soin ça n'a pas été très
compliqué pour lui le commissariat de
rambouillet
il ya une grande esplanade devant
qui est totalement dégagé quelques
marches qui permettent de monter au sas
d'accès et il ne présente pas de
problème de sécurité particulier ce sas
sas comme un autre il avait
préalablement repéré les lieux
stéphanie était une cible facile c'était
savait qu'il allait c'était prémédité
mais il s'est attaqué à stéphanie comme
il aurait pu s'attaquer à tous les voilà
les autres alors ce qu'on pourrait dire
comme ils se rattachent à n'importe qui
d'autre elle sait qu'un aménagement de
ministres hâtive donc c'est une cible
facile elle n'était pas armée
ça n'était pas fort bien sûr se défendre
ces gens là ne font pas preuve d'un
grand courage en général quand ea com
est ce type d'acte et pour lui ça a été
très très simple il a suffi qu'ils se
saisissent de son couteau qu'il tombe
dessus et qu'il qui ce qu'ils vous ont
dit les collègues qui étaient là bas
vous vécu ce drame il était à la fois
très choqué mais très opérationnelle
chacun reste est vraiment à sa place moi
la scène may hamm a été décrite à la
perfection ce qu'on vous a décrit comme
scène pour nos téléspectateurs
qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit hu a décrit
stéphanie qui rentrait dans le
commissariat et l'agresseur qui arrivait
avec son couteau que les gens à
l'intérieur du commissariat loyer et lui
disait attention mais il lui a pas
laissé un instant
bien heureusement j'ai un autre collègue
qui était sur place qui a pu faire usage
de son arme quasi instantanément
neutraliser le terroriste mais
malheureusement d'autres collègues aussi
de lui de lui donner premiers secours ça
n'a pas été possible
la blessure était été mortels
aujourd'hui je voudrais surtout vraiment
surtout avoir une pensée profonde pour
stéphanie pour ce qu'elle était aussi
pour sa famille pour son époux syfy et
pour tous ses amis particulièrement pour
notre collègue rené qui partageait son
bureau avec elle et c'était une agent
administratif dans un commissariat mais
surtout comme rambouillet quelqu'un de
très discret quelqu'un qu'on ne remarque
pas mais sans qui rien ne peut
fonctionner les administratifs au
commissariat de rambouillet ne sont pas
nombreux me sont le coeur du
commissariat et c'est d'autant plus
lâches comme attac que c'est quelqu'un
qui ne pouvait pas répondre d'un chien
voilà et ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je tenais à mettre en avant
j'ai une collègue qui s'est permis et ça
nous avons tous trouvé ça abjecte
haut-commissaire nous avons été très
choqués de faire de la récupération en
passant dans plusieurs médias
en déclarant qu'elle était très ami avec
elle qu'elle la connaissait très bien
alors que ce n'était absolument pas le
cas et qui a donné les détails de son
bureau la photo de ses enfants à quel
endroit
tout ça pour se donner
une image faire sa promotion régler ses
comptes très certainement avec la
hiérarchie locale en disant que ça
s'était mal sécurisés qu'on attendait
longtemps ce qui est absolument faux
et cette récupération sordide pour
régler des comptes personnels
nous avons tous été vraiment très
choquée j'ai évoqué ce problème là avec
mes collègues et amis tout à l'heure
lors de lors de l'hommage et j'aurais
dit qu'est ce que vous aimeriez qu'on
puisse dire pour elle
vous moi je sais déjà ce que j'aimerais
dire tous ont été unanimes dire qu'elle
aimait son boulot que c'était une
employée administrative qu'elle était
fière d'être une administrative
on a beaucoup vu que c'était une
policière non c'était une agent
administratif du ministère de
l'intérieur a été très fier de son
statut et est donc vraiment vraiment lui
rendre hommage à avoir une pensée pour
elle et sa famille voilà merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce été le
témoin du jour
oui bernard mouliné en est bouleversée
par cette affaire évidemment on pense à
cette dame à ses amis et sa famille mais
je crois qu'à une haine de la république
comme ça qui est quand même très
bouleversante et très choquant que ce
soit une haine contre la police qui se
développe de plus en plus on le voit
d'ailleurs où même les pompiers qui se
font caillasser
je crois qu'il faut arriver à renouer le
dialogue c'est pas possible de continuer
comme ça tout ça est extrêmement
dramatique surtout surtout on pense à
fanny on se dit bien sûr stéphanie bien
sûr rien demandé qui était qui étaient
là qui était une administrative l ipad
que pouvait pas se défendre
ccc c'est vraiment c'est sordide oui
j'ai le relais c'est incroyable
effectivement elle n'était pas protégée
et moi j'ai été bouleversée aussi par
l'immense dignité de la famille
cc je trouve qu'ils sont d'une d'un
courage admirable
il faut protéger les policiers il faut
les protéger parce que c'est cesser on a
l'impression d'avoir tous étaient
frappés ccc cebula stéphanie chacun
d'entre nous et le fait qu'elle n'ait
pas d'uniforme voilà quand on la voit
comme ça sur le poteau c'est vrai que ça
ça nous a tous fait très mal voilà
presque seulement quelqu'un qui n'est
pas une once de haine et de méchanceté
elle était vraiment c'était là la femme
la plus gentille du commissariat
j'en veux dire tout simplement et puis
qui ne demandait rien à personne n'avait
vu sa famille je les ai aperçus tout à
l'heure alors de l'hommage
c'est vrai que j'ai été plus ça on a
découvert la relation avec avec mes
collègues choqué comme eux par cette
perte
choqué par la récupération sordide et
anna fait notre autre notre collègue et
est donc moi sa famille chez que je suis
à leur disposition pour ce qui est tout
ce qui va être la reconnaissance pour
les enfants de pupille de la nation pour
ce qui va être tout l'accompagnement
nécessaire s'ils en ont besoin je serai
là comme tous les autres collègues sur
rambouillet présentes pour cette famille
parce que nous nous sommes tous un corps
solidaire et temps les actifs que les
administratifs au ministère de
l'intérieur il faut bien le souligner et
encore une fois je le répète on pense au
service actif de police on oublie tout
le temps les administratifs ils sont
quand même le coeur du système
et oui merci fanni était le coeur du
système